I met Osama on social media he commented
about my artwork and he was very
complementary
and every now and then I'd get another
message and then all of a sudden he's
he's like a tree that takes root in your
heart
[Music]
we had so much in common and he would
send me pictures of his paintings and
poetry and it encouraged me and gave me
hope that he was a genuine person I just
wanted to be with someone
that that says hey I get you Debbie
and so after about six months talking
online I decided to get on a plane and
go to Morocco and and visit with Osama
I knew Osama was younger but I didn't
know how much younger until we met in
person
at first I said look Osama I just can't
do this you're too young but he made me
see that it wasn't about the age and
circumstances it's about a deeper level
of connectivity and us being a team he's
24 years old
but I love them
Osama knows I take a lot of supplements
these vitamins are real important to me
I gotta look good you know I'm going to
be the best and youngest Debbie I can be
I've known Osama a little over three
years now I've only been to Morocco
twice but after years of communicating
Osama said Debbie come to Morocco and be
my wife so now I'm fixing to move to
Morocco in two weeks
foreign